[Applause]
I've never met we've met on the internet
which never met in person I I am having
the experience that you're having with
Kelly I'm having it about you like to
say as a fellow person in the queer
community I am so amazed by you I think
the fact that the Human Rights Campaign
is honoring you is not enough I we're
gonna just think that your work in
general is so beautiful and so thrilling
but the thing that you've done which i
think is so incredible is that you've
introduced audiences to this character
who just so happens to be who he is and
like that is the way to create change
social change empathy in people it's so
[Applause]
you look stunning
whatever number you put together Winkle
yes you are vision certified vision your
character Brooklyn nine-nine is openly
buy and like we're discussing like how
do you think cuz I feel like when you do
you're correct when you introduce these
characters on normal everyday television
it makes people not fear what they don't
know and almost open up to be like
everyone's not the same and that's okay
and I think it's kind of helped with
that impact I absolutely think so I mean
it really is like spoonful of sugar you
know I mean like we got you with those
laughs we got and then we're gonna keep
you coming right and and by the time
that you've that you've introduced of
times I think was first season for you
guys right first or second season okay
so by the time you've introduced it
you've already got the audience like in
love with you they already know you they
trust you you're funny or having a good
time and then suddenly for maybe quite a
few people they've never met any but
you're gonna be the first person that
they're meeting yeah that is that that
identifies that where is that sexuality
and for me specifically it was like
there's just so little representation
across the board for Latinas and
television Latinas
and so for me to be latina and queer and
bi and be playing a bi character and
also be openly by myself is like it's a
beautiful job I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this